"У-ес тридцять" як привіт з радянського минулого.
Цією бормашинкою лікують зуби в сільській амбулаторії за 90 кілометрів від Києва.
Працює, бачите!
Цей зубний кабінет в селищі Пісківка Бородянського району
щодня відвідують щонайменше троє-п'ятеро пацієнтів.
Фінансується він з районного бюджету, і витрати на нього вже давно зведено до мінімуму,
розповідає медсестра Зінаїда Олександрівна.
Жінка не виключає, що кабінет взагалі доведеться закрити,
адже, відповідно до медреформи, стоматологію держава не планує фінансувати.
Якщо не передбачений стоматолог - а в нас він тут не передбачений - то нас, звісно, викинуть!
Безкоштовного стоматолога в цій амбулаторії, вірогідно, не буде.
У результаті медфреформи заклад зможе надавати пацієнтам безкоштовно
лише чітко визначені державою послуги в розрахунку в середньому 370 гривень на рік
на кожного дорослого пацієнта плюс 740 гривень на пенсіонерів та дітей.
Чотири місцеві сімейні лікарки і терапевт, фактично, робитимуть те, що й раніше.
Спектр їхніх можливостей навіть розшириться
завдяки новому обладнанню, яке надається в рамках реформи.
Пульсоксіметри отримали. Ось такі.
Це щоб визначати насиченість крові киснем.
Проте до медреформи тут не готові.
Перш ніж втілювати в життя зміни,лікарі мають підписати з пацієнтами декларації.
Лікарки розраховують, що з ними ці декларації підпишуть
близькодев'яти тисяч мешканців Пісківки і трьох сусідніх селищ.
Проте, згідно з реформою, люди можуть обрати собі лікаря, наприклад, у райцентрі чи навіть у Києві.
Багато мешканців села взагалі ще не визначилися,
чи будуть вони підписувати декларацію з місцевими лікарями.
Я в Києві давним-давно лікуюся, то якщо треба - їду в Київ.
У Бородянці -туди тільки помирати.
Туди як попав, то все вже…
У нас місцеві лікарі дуже хороші. Звичайно, буду. З нашими місцевими лікарями.
От для менеця медфреорма-це темнийліс. Не розумію я ії!
У нас поки в Пісківці нічого не буде, тому що в нас комп'ютеризації немає.
Комп'ютери в місцевій амбулаторії дійсно з'явилися лише недавно.
І лікарки на них не дуже знаються.
Тож, поки що жоднадекларація в Пісквці ще не внесена в електронний реєстр пацієнтів.
Якби нам якісь курси організували, заклали нам програму в комп’ютер,
ми б тоді спокійно все дізналися і спокійно почали працювати.
Якщо немає декларацій, Пісківка не зможе отримати гроші на свою первинну медицину.
Адже у Національній службі здоров'я
обсяг фінансування визначають відповідно до кількості пацієнтів.
Крім того, Пісківка ще не пройшла до кінця юридичний шлях
створення комунального центру первинної допомоги
і отримання ліцензії на медичну практику.
Люди сподіваються, що після цього реформа в селі піде швидше.
І що село отримає бодай більш-менш придатну машину "швидкої".
Ну шо вам казати! Польові умови…
А поки медреформа не запрацює, селами Київщини і далі їздитимуть от такі старенькі "уазики"…